[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal dans
l'actualité départementale aujourd'hui
elle les chiffres du chômage en baisse
dans les yvelines - 2,2 pour cent par
rapport au mois dernier une bonne
nouvelle qui profite principalement aux
plus jeunes vous le verrez à satory
l'armée de terre organisé la semaine
passée une démonstration de son arsenal
et de sa base militaire le tout devant
une centaine d'invités et de nombreux
journalistes et puis une rencontre
insolite dans ce journal est celle d'une
championne de karaté de taekwondo
hollandaise d'origine soraya ouahdoudi
était de passage il y a quelques jours à
saint quentin en yvelines non on ouvre
ce journal avec une nouvelle réunion à
la préfecture de versailles à propos de
l'accueil des migrants sur le
département la sphère fait polémique
depuis plusieurs semaines le préfet des
yvelines a donc réuni une nouvelle fois
tous les acteurs du dossier peu
d'informations ont filtré sur le sujet
excepté un tweet celui du maire les
républicains du chéné philippe brillault
celui ci indique une centaine de
personnes devraient arriver dans une
dizaine de jours sur le site de l'inria
à rocquencourt pour une période maximum
de deux mois pour rappel le département
des yvelines accueille déjà un peu plus
de 400 migrants sur le territoire et sur
plusieurs sites depuis l'été 2015 c'est
arrivé font suite au démantèlement de
campements parisien en politique jean
frédéric poisson député des yvelines est
candidat à la primaire de la droite et
du centre n'est finalement pas exclu de
la course à la présidentielle le
président du parti chrétien démocrate
était mise en cause pour des propos sur
les lobbys sionistes la haute autorité
de la primaire a finalement décidé de ne
pas l'exclure mais lui rappelle
cependant qu'il devra soutenir le futur
gagnant de la primaire comme il s'y
était engagé au départ dans le reste de
l'actualité aujourd'hui les bons
chiffres du chômage du mois de septembre
nous vous en parlions déjà dans notre
édition d'hier soir
- 2,2 pour cent de demandeurs d'emploi
dans les yvelines par rapport au mois
d'août et ses beaux chiffres profite
surtout aux 25 et 49 ans osman vendeur
d'un autre expert économie elle nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau alors haussmann
est ce que on peut enfin parler de cette
fameuse inversion de la courbe du
chômage est bien en tout cas pour le
président de la république ce sont des
chiffres providentiel au neuvième mois
de l'année le nombre d'inscrits à pôle
emploi a diminué de 66 1300 personnes en
france soit un recul de 1,9 pour cent au
niveau national et les yvelines tirent
leur épingle du jeu avec 2,2 pour cent
les yvelines qui comptabilisait fin août
65000 780 personnes au chômage enfin à
pôle emploi est aujourd'hui fin
septembre nous sommes à 64 mille
personnes c'est l'une des plus forte
baisse enregistrée depuis décembre 2000
alors pourquoi ces chiffres haussmann
ont-ils autant baisser ce mois ci est
bien la version de la courbe du chemin
c'est une des promesses de françois
hollande et il a mis toutes et toutes
les choses en ordre pour pouvoir le
faire comme le pacte de responsabilité
les emplois aidés les primes à
l'embauché tout fonctionne à fond on
peut le dire c'est pour cette raison on
cite d'ailleurs que c'est la catégorie a
et les plus jeunes qui sont touchés par
cette forte baisse parce que c'était
l'une des promesses de françois hollande
permettre aux jeunes de retourner sur le
marché de l'emploi il y aussi cette
fameuse ce plan formation qui doit
permettre à un million de personnes de
pouvoir les suivre et donc il y a
plusieurs organismes qui contribuent
comme pôle emploi ou encore face un club
d'entreprises saint quentinois qui aide
au retour à l'emploi je vous laisse
écouter clarisse gorce chargée de
mission emploi à face
alors apparemment haussmann on a un
problème des interviews mais on a bien
compris en tout cas qu'on avait un début
d'inversion dans la courbe du chômage
merci haussmann pour ces précisions une
autre actualité dont on vous parlait
déjà hier la situation de 150
travailleurs sans papiers qui ont occupé
pendant plusieurs heures le siège de
sodexo à guyancourt les îles réclame des
documents pour pouvoir ensuite ré être
régularisée après une réunion avec la
direction du groupe de restauration
collective le siège a été finalement
levée sodexo s'engage notamment à lancer
une procédure pour que les documents des
sans papiers soient faits et à
réexaminer les dossiers de certains est
licencié jeudi dernier la base militaire
de satory a fait une démonstration de
son arsenal et de sa base d'entraînement
ainsi des dizaines de journalistes et
une centaine de personnes ont pu
découvrir et assister à cette
démonstration de force de l'armée de
terre reportage d'haussmann à 22h des
généreux d'un courage
devant un public constitué de militaires
de journalistes de famille de
délégations du monde entier
l'armée terre a fait une démonstration
de force c'est une journée
traditionnelle qui permet de créer des
liens avec ses alliés alors aujourd'hui
c'est une journée traditionnelle de
présentation de l'armée terre ali à
shenzhen voilà puis au fil du temps on a
élargi un petit peu la présentation de
manière à en faire profiter le maximum
de gens dont notamment les attachés de
défense tous les attachés de défense des
pays avec lesquels la france
et amis et parmi les délégations
présentes il y avait le japon une partie
de l'afrique de l'ouest comme la côte
d'ivoire le mali et le sénégal ou encore
le brésil et l'argentine
ils ont pu voir durant la démonstration
l'équipement que les militaires de
l'armée de terre utilisent au mali ou en
irak par exemple donc sa présentation
avait vocation à rassembler un certain
nombre de composantes de matériel de
l'aviation légère de l'armée de terre on
a pu voir un certain nombre
d'hélicoptères du nh90 caïman aux pumas
en passant par le tir mais aussi on a vu
des groupes tactiques interarmes composé
de diverses matériel que sont le leclerc
les mx 10 p
élevé bci eux
étaient joints aussi un certain nombre
de matériels
présenté sous la forme du convoi
logistique et puis sans oublier bien
entendu les artilleurs avec le césar le
but de ce type de démonstration est
aussi de séduire le public l'armée de
terre souhaite recruter 11000 personnes
avant l'été 2010 est
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines des travaux
vont perturber la chaussée et le trafic
demain et après demain sur l'avenue de
la villedieu à elancourt la circulation
automobile sera ainsi interdite entre 8h
et 18h sur une partie de l'avenue de
lavilledieu est cette ligne de bus du
réseau de l'agglomération de saint
quentin seront également impactée plus
de précisions sur le site internet de la
ville et l'encours ville tirés elancourt
point fr autre information pour les
usagers des transports à saint quentin
en yvelines vous avez sans doute
remarqué que certains bus ont changé de
look un changements impulsés avec le
passage de 7 à 12 communes dans
l'agglomération commencé au début du
mois d'octobre ce pelliculage qu'on voit
à l'écran devrait se terminer d'ici à la
fin du mois de novembre 80 un véhicule
porteront ses nouvelles couleurs écoutez
à ce propos le responsable de l'offre de
transport du réseau stibus au micro de
mélanie poquet
normalement on fait les changements sur
deux sites en même temps ce qu'on a
trois transporteurs ici on est chez
perrier et à la savak et yao poule donc
en général on travaille toujours sur
deux sites en même temps donc minimum il
ya deux véhicules qui sont faits puis là
comme aujourd'hui il y en a deux sur ce
dépôt là et si on a un chez eux à saint
max en fait deux à trois par jour
c'est un savoir faire ancestral que vous
pouvez pratiquer en atelier la religion
soit le fait de protéger et d'embellir
un livre avec un habillage et c'est
l'une des activités proposées en ce
moment au centre alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux nous sommes allés
suivre un cours présentation de cette
technique en images avec camille lambert
un geste précis presque chirurgicale
play war scalpel pinceaux avec minutie
pierre et neuf ses livres issus de sa
bibliothèque personnelle un travail mené
depuis quelques années pour restaurer sa
collection 250 ouvrages on met une carte
de couverture que vous voyez là on fait
des coutures de l'ensemble de l'ensemble
des publics des coûts luc couture de
cahiers on les relier ensemble et après
on habille ont fait l'habillage de la
livre donc l'habillage du livre ça
consiste à bas par exemple j'ai des deux
mis dos en cuir et papiers et de l'art
est empaqueté avec des coins cuir
réparer protéger embellir la reliure est
considérée comme un art depuis les
romains ce savoir faire ancestral peut
désormais se pratiquer en atelier comme
ici au centre alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux sous l'oeil
attentif de juliette les élèves
s'appliquent à suivre les différentes
étapes faut savoir qu'un livre on a à
peu près 40 opérations différentes
on monte les couvertures
on coud le livre sur un couloir donc on
recourt tout le livre on lan coll je
pense qu'il faut être un petit peu
patient un petit peu soigneux l'après de
la précision parce que ça demande quand
même
quelque chose faut que la culture soit
bien bien serré
tout le monde peut faire de l'argent
j'aime ou j'aime bien la matière le
papier le la peau moi je veux lui donner
une autre vie à une couverture avec du
décor éventuellement
la reliure est une activité proposée
depuis cinq ans par le centre en moyenne
10 à 15 heures de travail sont
nécessaires pour faire un livre un
véritable patrimoine transmis tous les
mardis à voisins le bretonneux
on referme ce journal avec une rencontre
insolite soraya watts judi l'une des
plus grande championne de karaté de
taekwondo au monde était à saint quentin
en yvelines le week-end dernier pour
passer du temps en famille la sportive a
profité de son temps libre pour réaliser
des vidéos pour les réseaux sociaux un
reportage de michael et les minéraux et
de patrick jacques de dixmude
la hollandaise soraya moi je vous dis 18
ans l'une des plus grandes championnes
de taekwondo et de karaté au monde et à
saint quentin en yvelines la sportive a
passé quelques jours en famille chez son
grand-père à montigny le bretonneux pour
les vacances l'expert en art martial en
a profité pour réaliser des vidéos dans
la commune yvelinoise afin de diffuser
sa passion sur les réseaux sociaux
décosse j'ai commencé le karaté à quatre
ans parce que mon père faisait du karaté
il m'a emmené voir un court je me suis
dit waouh c'est vraiment sympa alors
j'ai commencé
mon sentiment par rapport au karaté
c'est que quand je fais ce sport
je fais ce que j'aime et j'adore
divertir les gens depuis ses débuts la
hollandaise volante est vu par les
observateurs comme un prodige des
espoirs confirmés par ses performances
sportives son oreille a remporté des
dizaines de trophées majeurs
j'ai gagné le tournoi de hollande
d'angleterre d'allemagne de belgique
d'autriche et le tournoi européen la
smart event et au pérou le mois dernier
je suis allé au pérou pour les
championnats du monde de taekwondo
j'ai fini troisième donc je suis la
troisième mondiale la sportive a
également participé à plusieurs
émissions de télévision comme la version
hollandaise d'un incroyable talent en
mai dernier le show est regardé par
plusieurs millions de téléspectateurs
j'ai fait du karaté en freestyle pour
cette émission avec deux autres filles
j'ai fait des chorégraphies avec un
sabre un bâton est également un combat à
18 ans aurait ya espère désormais
participer aux prochains jeux olympiques
et tourné dans des films ou des
publicités
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à revoir bien sûr son autre site
internet tv fil 78 points comme à demain
pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal
[Musique]